veamos qué dice aquí si se utiliza la
calculadora y encuentra el ángulo al
grado más próximo cuyo valor de la
tangente es 0.8 75 entonces el ángulo al
tangente de 0.8 75 cuál crees que será
la respuesta primero lo primero debemos
tener cuidado con lo que se nos pide no
se nos pregunta o no se nos pide que
encontremos la tangente de 0.8 75 no
dice que 0.8 75 es un ángulo y queremos
encontrar la tangente de ese ángulo no a
esto tache no no se nos pide eso
preguntan algo muy distinto dice que hay
un ángulo el cual tal vez podemos llamar
teta y si tomamos la tangente de ese
ángulo entonces vamos a obtener 8.0
perdón 0.8 75 y bueno como podemos
encontrar ese ángulo misterioso usando
la calculadora como le podemos hacer
para eso la manera cómo le hacemos aquí
es utilizando algo que llamamos la
función inversa de la tangente o en
ocasiones llamado la función arco
tangente y eso
realmente si aplicas eso si miras a esto
como una ecuación y sacas la función
inversa de la tangente entonces tomas la
inversa de la tangente de esto y tomas
la inversa la tangente de esto aunque
mejor voy a voy a borrar esto un poco
para hacerlo tener más espacio entonces
bueno aquí tangente a la menos 1 indica
la empresa de la tangente de 0.8 75 en
el lado izquierdo solamente te queda el
ángulo theta y en el lado derecho
tenemos la tangente inversa de 0.8 75 si
tienes si tienes la calculadora al modo
de ángulo esto se va a regresar a grados
si lo tienes en modo de radiales tendrás
un ángulo en modo de radiales pero
usando la calculadora para resolver esto
podemos usar la calculadora tradicional
la boya la voy a sacar aquí y bueno
entonces por lo que tenemos aquí escrito
y aquí ya puedes ver puedes ver la
tangente no veo la inversa para la para
la tangente pero podemos tener la
inversa presionando el botón de inversa
que está aquí no lo confunda con el
botón de recíproco ves este no es seno
este es el de la inversa para funciones
pero
es la inversa y notas que esto cambio ya
tienes aquí la función inversa de
tangente y ahora bueno al fin podemos
poner en 0.8 75 y obtener la inversa de
eso así que 0 punto punto 8 7-5 y
tomamos la tangente inversa de eso aquí
podemos ver que ya lo puse en grados
queremos redondear lo al grado más
próximo y bueno tenemos 41
aproximadamente 41 grados por lo tanto
es ese es el ángulo teta es
aproximadamente no exactamente 41 grados
entonces bueno ahora hagamos lo mismo
con la gráfica dora así que la sacó aquí
está y la enciendo y por lo que tengo
aquí ya escrito queremos la tangente
inversa en esta en esta calculadora
también puedes ver la palabra tan de
tangente y arriba dice tan a la menos 1
pero no se retira la potencia sino a la
función inversa de la tangente y para
acceder a esa función simplemente
presionas el botón segunda este botón
naranja y obtienes tangente inversa
tangente inversa de cero
875 obtienes el exactamente el mismo
valor aproximadamente 41 grados
redondeado al grado más cercano y ahí lo
tenemos